everything that Apple has ever done is
all leading to this the Apple Vision Pro
here it
is spatial Computing is the newest term
that you'll hear be tossed around and
until you actually experience the Apple
Vision Pro in real life it might be hard
to grasp now I know it was for me until
I put this headset on for the first time
and everything just clicked its ability
to transport you into another world
while staying inside of your comfy cozy
Apple eco system is what really sets
this apart from other headsets of course
the price does as well but this really
is unlike anything I've ever experienced
the entire headset is so nice and
everything feels like a high quality
Apple product as you'd expect it's got
this beautiful aluminum frame with a
digital crown and this button right on
top it kind of looks like a stretched
out Apple watch if you really look at it
the front is made of a custom curved
glass and under it is actually a display
that will showcase to the outside world
when you're watching content or a little
dis display A visual representation of
the user's eyes when you're talking to
someone now the inside is an ultra high
resolution display that has 23 million
pixels across the two displays which is
more than a 4K TV for each one of your
eyes the most impressive thing about it
though is the way that it just feels
intuitive as soon as you put it on the
natural way you just look at something
and you make a pinching gesture to
select it and it just freaking works
like it truly feels like you're
witnessing a miracle now before we get
more into this let's do my favorite
thing and unbox it
I'm going to have a heart attack because
I'm like sweating and I'm so nervous
okay
okay let's unbox
it oh my goodness are you guys ready cuz
I'm not sure if I
[Music]
am oh my goodness here it is Apple
Vision Pro I like it little protective
hat and it matches the solo knit loop
it's just just it's got such a little
cozy Vibe this thing is just sitting
there right in the box and it is
ready to set up oh my gosh this is
really just it it's kind of a Monumental
moment what okay that's kind of cool
like check this out like it's just
sitting
there it's
perfectly like it doesn't move it
doesn't go anywhere it's just like
floating oh my goodness okay I want to
take off its little little cover take a
sneak peek
ready oh shoot check that out look at it
this is the future the future is in my
hands right
now oh it's so soft like this is
something that I wish they made like a
sweatshirt out of this because I would
wear it 100% let's see what else is in
the box I'm going to put its little
cover back on sh go
see so what have we got in
here go she's so lucky like she is she
is Vision Pro she is everywhere so
here's everything in the
Box you get it now inside here is our
dual band Loop so this does come with
two different bands depending upon which
one fits your preference I kind of like
the do Loop band because it seems to
alleviate a lot of the pressure of the
device here it is it's kind of just like
a Big Apple watch band but for your head
we've got a USBC cable we've got the
battery pack which is such a beautiful
battery pack like if Apple made one of
these just to like charge my phone I'd
buy two think about it and this is a
little connector that goes into the side
it isn't mag safe it is actually
mechanical so you do have to place it in
and then turn it which is good because
this keeps it in place if it was mag
safe you don't want this turning off mid
activity and we've got a charging
brick what's in here we still have more
things a polishing cloth can you even
believe it oh this is a nice so this is
a special Vision Pro polishing cloth
it's a much thinner texture than the
polishing cloths that they have for your
computer also smells new and fresh okay
I haven't seen a sticker
yet all right this is the extra light
seal cushion that they give you there's
one that's a little bit thicker so
depending upon the fit you can figure
out which one's right for
you so here's everything that comes in
the Apple Vision Pro box we've got our
headset external battery pack charging
brick USBC cable polishing cloth extra
light seal the solo knit band and the DU
band Loop the other thing that we have
to unbox to show you are the Zeiss
Optical lenses now this is something
that you can order if you have
prescription lenses you can get them if
you're near size it or far sided now
these are just some readers as a demo to
show you how to insert them they go in
magnetically so if you do wear contacts
you don't actually have to buy these so
I'll show you how these
work there they are so these will just
pop right on like inserts to The Vision
Pro that's it and they're on that was
easy now this is the Vision Pro case
obviously it is sold separately it's a
little wrinkled I think that's the style
that they're going for I'm kind of into
it it's a nice fresh white and up here
we've got the Vision Pro travel case tag
let's open it and see what it looks like
I like this nice little handle here that
actually comes out a little bit so you
can carry it it's so squishy like
actually this could be a nice travel
pillow like I 100% would use this on the
plane like I would oh it's so soft and
so so
nice look at that Vision Pro travel case
we've got some documentation okay so
this shows you how to put it in cuz I I
was curious okay so that's where you
clip in the
battery
a little baggie oh it's a little
accessory
pouch oh that's so nice now we put
Vision Pro in and this is cool it's got
like a little adjustable slider because
depending upon what size light seal and
cushion that you have you might need to
adjust it so I do have the small so
pushing that all the way forward and
we've got this cute little bag to put
all of our accessories in check this out
look at this
I see why this was so expensive because
it is a really nice case I get
it and there we go Apple Vision Pro is
ready to go this does have a travel mode
so if you are on a plane a train or if
you're the passenger of a car you can
set that into travel mode so be able to
use this while you're moving I won't be
testing that out here in this video but
stay tuned for a future one where I take
it on the go and see what it's like now
the moment that we've all been waiting
for let's set it
up
[Music]
all right just want to give you guys a
little look at the headset so obviously
we've got our little cover on here so
when we take it off we are greeted with
this beautiful front display now this is
a modular system so if we don't want to
have the solo knit Loop we can just pop
this right off we've got these little
pull tabs right here can just pull pop
them off and then we can just put on the
Dual Loop band so what's cool is is if
you do want to give someone guest access
and they have a different size head you
just need to order the different size
light seal and the cushion and this will
allow you to just Swap this out to give
someone access to guest mode now this
device can only be registered to one
person so using optic ID this will
basically be sealed to you they will be
able to go into guest mode so we'll test
that out later going to take off our
little like it kind of looks like a bra
like I'm just going to say it like it's
it is what it is I'm so nervous like I
feel I feel warm so you just line up the
little dots to the circle and then you
rotate and we are dialed in so you'll
see there's a little light right there
it's blinking now it's going to keep
blinking and as soon as it turns solid
then the headset is ready to be put on
there is an initial setup process that
you have to go through you only have to
do this once when you first get the
device and then it'll automatically be
calibrated to you the coolest thing
though is the way that this is able to
detect your eye
tracking looks like we have a solid
light it's time to go in I can't believe
this moment is here so the solo knit has
a little tightener right back here so
you just tighten that to get a nice snug
fit I'm going to press this to hold to
align my
eyeballs oh my
gosh it's happening wo there's an Apple
logo that just popped up I can see I can
see everything I see you a little hello
has just written itself across my screen
oh my gosh all right so now it's telling
me to bring my iPhone iPad nearby to get
started so let's set it up this is so
I'm using my phone right now and and
it's like I am seeing with my real eyes
all right so this is the first time that
you guys are seeing what I'm seeing the
cool thing is basically on day one we're
going to have access to over a million
apps because of the App Store with all
the iPhone apps the iPad apps a lot of
these are compatible with Vision Pro so
it's super exciting that we will be able
to use a lot of those apps seamlessly
right on the Vision Pro day one this is
what the Vision Pro App Store looks
like now the tech in this thing is what
is really so impressive just the cameras
and the sensors alone and the way that
they are able to duplicate such a real
life experience with the pass through
video there's two main cameras on the
front two on the side two IR
illuminators four four downward cameras
two true depth cameras and a light R
scanner right in the front with all of
these this lets you casually have your
hands placed on your lap to the side or
really almost anywhere and still be able
to pinch to select now doing a FaceTime
in Vision Pro I will say is probably one
of the wildest experiences oh my gosh
okay we were just debating like what is
what's what's your hair stripe going to
look like it kind of looks Blended out
right it doesn't get the spikiness but
it's there yeah right yeah the faces are
impressive I think right very very it's
it's just at the edge of uncanny valley
like I know what you guys look like so I
know that they look like you this is
like like I mean I feel like this is
like a nine out of 10 like of how we
actually look it's pretty good and also
like skin tones too cuz we've all three
of us have very different complexions
too and I feel like it actually I think
it did a pretty good job every single
time I get on a FaceTime call with this
it's the same reaction of whoa like this
is weird and I realize I've gotten used
to it and I think after a while everyone
using this is just going to get used to
it after you get over the initial holy
crap look at this thing well thank you
guys this was cool this is this is dope
this is dope thumbs thumbs I see I saw
more of one of his okay bye
[Music]
y'all so now that I have everything all
set up I want to take you through how to
actually use Vision Pro this is the
I don't want to say it's even
challenging because it's super easy so
if this is the most challenging part
then you're going to be set up for
Success after this because it's so
simple it's so intuitive and it really
is amazing how accurate the eye tracking
is it's made me feel really strange now
in the real world because when I'm
looking at something it's hard for my
brain to comprehend that I can't look at
it pinch and bring it closer to myself
oh Apple Vision Pro side effects all
right I'm going in okay I'm now inside
and as you can see I can see everything
that's happening here so we've got a
little Studio light here got you right
there on my camera hello got Armand over
there hello and it doesn't feel like
I've left my living room like I am still
in it now the interesting thing is it's
so realistic but also it does have that
slight feel that you're looking at a
screen so it is kind of confusing to
your brain but for the most part I feel
like I'm looking around and things just
start popping up and it's so
unbelievable that I it's hard for me to
even articulate but let's just go
through and let me show you some things
on how this works so this is the digital
crown and when I press that that brings
up our main menu here when I want to go
and open something I literally just look
at it so as you see each icon kind of
getting a little bit highlighted and a
little bit bigger now you just use the
pinch
gesture to pinch and select things and
I'm using it to slide through the menu
use and that is basically that's it now
we're going to go into some settings and
I will show you my Persona that I
created so here it is this is my Persona
now I created this using the Vision Pro
you hold up the Vision Pro in front of
your face oh my gosh you can even see my
hands like this is wild and you go
through this process where you scan your
hands front and back and then you hold
the Vision Pro in front of your face so
you take it off of your head hold it in
front of you and you follow the
directions you look left you look right
up down you smile without your teeth you
smile with your teeth and then you raise
your eyebrows and then you close your
eyes and that is all it takes to create
your persona and this is in beta so it
is all still a work in progress but
you'll actually see that it gets all of
the details I wish I would have fixed my
necklace for this Persona shot you can
see it's a little bit crooked so it does
get the details pretty good I'm going to
close out of here I looked at the X I
closed it so now down here at the bottom
you see that big line that allows you to
move the windows so you look at it and I
can move this and put it wherever I want
I can move it oh my gosh it's so close
in front of my face now you can also
resize this window by looking at the
bottom corner this is in my space I have
a safari window open right here so now
if I look at the microphone that'll
allow me to use voice to text
youtube.com/ justen so here is my
YouTube channel now I can go and scroll
through and it's just so intuitive you
look at something and you click it now
when you see those hyperlinks becoming
active those are things that I'm looking
at right now so I'm watching this video
I don't want to be here anymore I want
to be somewhere else I'm going to go to
the moon so there are all sorts of
different environments that you can
choose from right now at the moon this
is full
environment like we are oh my gosh my
hands it's still shocking every single
time now there's other locations that I
can go to so when I look up here this
takes me to the control center look at
all of these that we can choose from so
let's go to hakala I always mispronounce
this but this is an incredible place in
Hawaii I've actually been here in real
life I am watching my own YouTube video
on this beautiful beautiful island if I
decide that I don't want to be fully
immersed I can dial this
back and you'll see that it goes away as
you
dial in the transparency so the headset
lets people know if you're actually
looking at them or if you're looking at
content so obviously I am watching some
content right now now if anybody else is
around they will not be able to see my
eyes but because I have my digital
Persona already added on here my
eyeballs will show up when I'm paying
attention or talking to someone else and
I'm not watching content so right now
I'm fully immersed get hi oh my gosh no
you're showing up now and you're
actually showing up more clear as I
talked to you yeah I could see your eyes
it's it kind of cool cuz it's like I'm
seeing you but you're also wearing these
goggles but I'm seeing you kind of like
you just sort of like a appeared out of
the
Rocks it's so cool all right so right
now I've opened up IM message and I have
a chat here with Armando who's over
there ironically and he's he's texting
me so it's cool because I can have our
chat just be right up here this is going
to be a great opportunity to show you
guys the virtual keyboard so I'm going
to write back the keyboard pops up and I
can put this wherever I want now the
typing on here is so wild because it it
kind of feels like I'm actually typing
this is all too much for me to handle
now there's three ways that you can type
you can use your voice you can look at
the letter and pinch or you can actually
press the keys so the first thing that
I'm going to do is I'm going to use the
actual keyboard so here we go I push the
key
yes
I and then I'm going to look up there
and I hit send now I'm going to try just
looking at the letters and pinching with
my hands now you don't have to make like
a huge gesture you just it's just a
simple little
[Music]
pinch said so now I'm going to use my
voice I'm going to look at the
icon actually I changed my mind I want
pizza thank you bye there we go I wonder
if I can add an image can I I can this
is basically just like freaking IM
message okay let's see okay now I'm
sending you pizza party okay cool well
I'm going to keep our chat just right up
here above my YouTube video so I'm also
not bringing up like my notes and all my
stuff because I have all my information
in there so you can use all of these
apps just like you normally would so I'm
going to open up keynote let's make a
new presentation oh I can connect to
keyboard okay now I have just I've got a
work station here magic keyboard there
it is connect magic Trackpad oh my gosh
look at this and the mouse cursor it
basically is like the little cursor that
shows up from like the iPad okay oh my
god oh this is so cool okay I'm shocked
because this is the first time that I'm
actually trying this Vision Pro is so
cool oh my God this is amazing this
makes it so much easier because I feel
like a lot of the eyee fatigue that I'm
feeling is from excessively like looking
around and I think as I use this more
I'll get used to it more where right now
I think I'm like actively looking at
something because I know that's how I
select whereas I feel it becoming more
second nature and it'll be less I feel
like exhausting after a
while this is M blowing to me okay so
I've still got our chat up there now I
want to find an image it's so cool cuz
when I start typing it just
automatically the keyboard just goes
away so if I want to copy an image I
just look at it I hold it
copy I'm going to look over here delete
that image and let's see if Apple V
works it does I just pasted it now if
you do want to paste this you just do
the same action you just hold this in
and it'll bring up a little selection
and you can click paste um I'm also
recording over here if you guys are
curious what this is for that's how I'm
screen recording everything and
hopefully I'm not making you completely
nauseous by looking around everywhere
this is pretty awesome okay I'm going to
go into this presentation mode and I can
choose an environment for my rehearsal
so we are going to go and transport to
the Steve Jobs theater to
rehearse for my presentation hello
everyone welcome to the Steve Jobs
theater uh it's Justine oh my God I
would probably die to be standing on the
stage at one point in my life
um what my presentation is actually back
there dude this is
wild H are we manifesting right now I
think we are I wonder if I stand up if
it'll if if it if I will stand up okay
when I stand up it
actually okay you guys can see this
because I'm screen recording but it it
actually knew that I was standing up and
showed me my surroundings so it's not
giving me the full view so I don't hurt
myself which is actually pretty free
freaking awesome there's my beautiful
work of art that I just
did wow oh I God I can even see the
carpet okay I got to sit back
down okay now that I've sat back down
everything has come back into view so
that's a really cool safety feature and
it happened so quickly I have a laser
pointer how does that work look oh my
gosh look at the laser pointer this is
so cool look at this I'm losing it this
is so cool when I'm having a bad day I'm
just going to come in here and I'm going
to sit in the Steve Jobs theater and
just make presentations there's now a
whole new app store for Vision Pro so
let's go check out some of those apps
I've already downloaded a few when I did
my setup there's a really cool hiking
one that I saw I want to check that one
out hiking and skiing Peak visor so I've
now connected into the immersive map
here it's downloading oh gosh this is
going to be so cool oh my goodness look
at all of this everywhere that I
look
I am I am swimming in the mountain you
suon Village tell me more about it and
then it just pops up right here it's
like up to my neck cho cho mountain is
it's on my neck check out this cool hike
in Yus we should do it one day it's
called Choo Cho Mountain choo choo choo
cho cho cho Choo come over soon and try
out Vision Pro that was way cooler than
I I actually thought it was going to be
sky guide oh my goodness oh my my good
oh oh
hello you go back where you belong I
feel like a
god what this is so cool also if you
want to reenter your little icons you
just have to press and hold on the
digital Crown so that'll give you a
different view just like so now it's
time to test out this app that I have
been dying to show you this is the DJ
app so here's what it looks like
normally on the iPad you can bring this
into your space like an actual DJ set
here it is okay so I'm going to move
this closer so that I don't have to get
up yeah this is great okay check this
out I can pick this up put it back down
I can
scratch that's not it look what else we
have we have
[Music]
effects oh you think that's it no it's
not it
look at all of these albums that have
just popped up that I can pull
out and put
[Music]
down I probably should stop dancing
because you guys are probably seeing my
head move around a lot you thought that
was it no we can go into different
environments oh look at
this everything is
awesome oh check this
out look at the
tunnel oh sh look we have people are
they going to dance do you want me to
change up the music maybe what's back
here
summer we love it okay they like this
now they're
dancing hey Clos DJ and we're back in
the living room let's see what else we
can do Apple arcade is huge there's so
many games to choose from you can play
iPad apps iPhone games and you can also
connect an Xbox controller or a
PlayStation controller a controller
through Bluetooth and I happen to have
my Xbox controller here that I actually
just use all the time when I play Xbox
and I'm going to play a game this is on
Apple arcade so if you have apple arcade
obviously you can you can play this so
like I have filled this screen basically
as large as I can here on my wall so as
you can see I'm using this Xbox
controller I think Jenna's here but I'm
busy like here we go I'm gaming I'm
gaming hey Maddie hi Angel mommy's
playing a video game I'm in the
future yeah but I am I'm playing sonic
right now come on up come on up buddy
okay so also what's cool is if I want to
go into an environment oh yeah this is
beautiful okay I'm going
to I'm gonna play my game in
peace look at
this and I can still see my hands so
this is something I can't wait to try
I'm going to mirror my display into my
headset and edit the video that you're
seeing right now ah this is going to be
so cool okay we're going in oh here's my
computer this is showing a little
connect I that's just popped up so let's
look at it we're
connecting and now
oh my goodness my freaking timeline is
now in front of my face oh my gosh Mo
the window so you
look this is unbelievable okay the only
problem is okay I don't know where all
my keys
are obviously I am watching some content
wow this is messing with my brain
because it looks so good like look at
this I'm just moving this all around my
room the other cool thing is if I wanted
I could bring up any other apps here I
could just have my YouTube channel over
here like this is just it's awesome
should I bring a dinosaur in we were
editing and now we're not look at this
little
butterfly oh my God it's it's touching
me I felt that I felt that um okay
you're it's so close to me dude dude I'm
honestly going to I'm so
[Music]
scared he's looking at my hand wow that
was a lot so Jenna came over to try out
Vision Pro now there is a really cool
guest mode that you can give access to a
guest and Jenna is my guest today okay
so I'm going to put this on and get
guest mode all set up for you and then
we're going to go through a little
tutorial o a tutorial you will be able
to experience Vision Pro so I open up
the apps that I wanted Jenna to be able
to view and then I hit guest mode okay
ready I think so oh let me get you a
fresh cushion this comes in two parts on
the website you can actually custom fit
these to your face so this is custom fit
to mine so the seal might not be perfect
for you but I feel like we have same
brain probably same face is it like a
small medium large type of number they
have different sizes and they didn't say
how many different sizes here you go how
do you loosen and tighten the band right
here yep right there and then oh make
sure you always grab it by
okay I'm learning there hold it to your
face and then give it a nice little okay
okay so I'm seeing what she's seeing now
so she's holding the digital Crown to
align it with her eyes so oh my gosh
look at that I can see my feet so this
is going to go through the whole process
that I went through initially to set up
your hands um yeah match the hands I see
it Go tap your fingers to select it I'm
looking at it okay look at each Dot and
then do a little pinch to select
okay now you're going to do it again in
a different lighting
condition I do like that I don't have to
move my head around cuz I feel like with
other VR moving my head around made me
ill MH but this I don't have to move it
okay it's completing your eye setup are
you ready to experience Apple Vision Pro
Jenna yes I am what am I going to what
do I have to look forward to oh well the
future you're in the future right now so
look at my socks okay so I opened up all
these apps already for you um let's see
hi oh my it's isn't it weird it's weird
cuz it's like I can see through you yeah
but me but you're not wow okay so these
are my spatial videos okay now look up
at the top where it's got that little
Pano button it looks like a little um
there you go when people are watching
the screen recording of this it's going
to just look kind of like it looks I'm
watching what you guys are seeing and it
just looks like tunnel vision but like
when you're in the headset what do you
see oh I feel like I can touch him it's
like I can I I mean I am touching it but
W it looks like it's going to touch me
I'm so excited to see what these look
like I haven't even seen any of these
yet it literally looks like the leaf is
touching me okay so now you're going to
go into a Disney plus environment which
is one of my favorite things because
apps like Disney Plus have the ability
to create these environments oh oh man
wow I'm in the theater you are in the
theater cup holder oh my goodness how
awesome okay now W wo this is so you're
gone
hi I don't see you I yeah okay well my
hands it looks like you're petting the
table I can't see it okay we're going to
watch Aladdin oh I'm excited have you
seen this I think I made you go see in
theaters mhm my hands are so bright can
you see my hands no I can see your hands
W okay so what do you think what does it
look like it looks it looks like I'm at
the movies this is really weird like it
feels like I'm at the movies this is
confusing for the brain I never liked 3D
cuz it made me kind of sick but I feel
like with this since I'm not like moving
my head that much and I'm not really
like moving around it's different it's a
different experience so unfortunately I
can't show you what she's seeing right
now in 3D because of copyright so you're
just going to have to uh to trust our
commentary here I it's like I'm there I
know come on out Jen okay I don't want
to it's fun in here I'm not welcome back
I'm not in the theater FaceTime Jenna
eeric oh my gosh so I have you in in the
Joshua Tree environment and your little
screen is actually showing a little
shadow on the rocks that I have you set
on this is going to be total Inception
okay so I'm carrying you right now I'm
walking around wa gosh I got so close
cuz I dropped you oh my God I'm freaking
out I am freaking out but I can't figure
out what's happening because I have this
okay this is so freaking wild because I
couldn't figure out like you were right
next to yourself we're really having a
fun time here but this looks like you're
really there nothing because this is
everything I wonder if I leave you there
if I lose you okay I'll bring you with
me okay here we go we'll be on the TV so
I'm going to share my keynote with you
that I've been working on okay I'm going
to take you into my presentation room oh
we're in the conference room I know look
and watch this when I turn around my
presentation is there it's a very nice
conference room so that's my slideshow
can you open the
blinds uh I don't think I can it's okay
great uh I'll do a followup next week
okay okay bye um hi okay so I was
walking around I forgot I needed to get
something in here and then I walk back
into this room but like the window is
right where I left
it like it's it's right here like it's I
left the window here in this room and I
I'm leaving now oh there okay yep uh-huh
careful when walking around the window
it stayed over there it's where I left
it this is so
so
[Music]
wild well thank you guys for watching I
know this is a long video but I was
trying to be as thorough as possible in
giving you guys the unboxing experience
and what it's like to actually use it
the only problem is a lot of the footage
that I'm showing you like it doesn't
look as good as it does in the headset
stuff that I'm showing you it looks
perfectly fine on screen but when it's
actually inside of this headset and in
your head it just looks so Crystal Clear
and everything is just so real life that
I cannot just enough how you got to try
it like if you're not going to buy one I
don't that's fine find a friend hop in
guest mode test it out go to the Apple
store and just use it because it needs
to be something that you experience just
so that you're getting your mind wrapped
around what the possible future looks
like for spatial Computing not only for
Apple but there's so many other headsets
that I feel like are going to be kind of
going in this direction so not only for
Content creation shooting spatial video
for advertisers for marketers like this
is a whole new world and it's here so
buckle up